أعلم أن الطريق ما زال بعيدًا ولكن إذا استمرت
هذه الأزمة أو هذه العلاقات المتوترة ،
فسنكون
قادرين على اللعب في كأس العالم في قطر
عندما تستضيفها في توريون
جيدًا حتى لو كانت الأزمة مستمرة.
لاعبي كرة القدم السعوديين
مرحب بهم في الدوحة ، فالشعب السعودي
مرحب به في الدوحة في الوقت الحالي ، فهم
محرومون من بلدهم
لكنهم غير مشاركين من قطر ، ولم
نقم بتسييس الرياضة أبدًا ، ولم نقم
بتسييس الثقافة التي لم
ننتقدها أبدًا التعليم أو حياة الناس.
إنه قرارهم أن ينتقدوها
من جانبهم ، فلا يمكننا فعل أي شيء
معهم ، كل شخص من دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
وبقية العالم ، حيث نرحب بكم في
الدوحة
ومرحبا بكم في لعب كرة القدم أو لعب أي
نوع من الرياضات الأخرى أو الدراسة أو
التدرب.  العمل حتى لا
أحد يُعاقب بسبب
عرقه أو بسبب خلفيته
كم من الوقت يمكنك الصمود أعني أنك
بلد غني ولكن هل هناك نقطة
كسر  أعني ما هو نوع
الضغط الذي تريده جيدًا قطر
ليس لدينا أي ضغط الضغط الرئيسي
الذي نملكه هو الضغط ماذا
عندما نرى أفراد عائلاتنا مفصولون ،
هذا هو الضغط الاقتصادي الوحيد
بعض التحديات في
البداية ثم يتم ذلك  نحن
حياتهم تحرك كل شيء ، النمو هو
واحد من الأفضل في المنطقة ، نحن
نمضي قدمًا في فتح خط
تجاري جديد شركاء تجاريين جدد ، ونحن نبني
مرونة أقوى للبلد
فيما يتعلق بالجوانب الأخرى إذا
لم يكن هناك  استفزاز
للبلاد لا يوجد تدخل في
التلاعب بالسوق لأنهم
يحاولون استفزاز أجوائنا أو محاولة
استفزاز شعبنا أو التحريض
ضدهم الحياة لا تتحرك شيء
لن يؤثر عليها ولكن هذا
الاستفزاز المستمر هو فقط يصنع حروب التوتر.